Зараз я продемонструю вам серце нашої стайні.
Саме тут розташована наша автоматична система.
Вона складається з двох окремих доїльних боксів - так званих доїльних роботів.
Вони доять наших корів автоматично 24 години на добу.
Худоба має повністю вільний доступ до системи й отримує тут трохи корму, так звані концентровані корми.
І тому корови так полюбляють приходити сюди на доїння.
Для мене, звісно ж, автоматичне доїння є величезною підмогою в моїй роботі,
адже це дає мені цілковиту гнучкість у моїй повсякденній роботі.
Раніше я мусив бути у стайні щодня о 6-ій ранку та о 6-ій вечора, щоб подоїти корів.
І навіть на вихідних або у святкові дні. Але коли ви напередодні ввечері були з друзями,
то доволі важко о 6-ій ранку знову бути у 100-відсотковій формі в доїльному цеху.
Для нас ситний сніданок вранці після стайні дуже важливий, аби добре стартувати в день.
Тому я щодня снідаю з родиною. Сьогодні тут моя подруга Аліна і моя мама Еріка.
Ми завжди вранці розмовляємо про те, що належить зробити протягом дня.
Мій дідусь косив вручну косою, сіно вручну вантажив і розвантажував, у відра корів доїв. Це була неймовірно виснажлива праця.
Я вчуся на вчительку і вважаю, що це робота, яка дозволяє також займатися сільським господарством і мати час для сім’ї.
І, власне, як я це бачу зараз, я ніби є його ментальним фоном і вловлюю його настрій, якщо щось іде не так.
Тож, гадаю, я можу зробити досить значний внесок навіть під час навчання.
За допомогою мобільного додатку я, приміром, можу побачити дані якоїсь корови, скажімо, Уте під номером 79.
Коли було останнє повідомлення? Скільки молока вона дала? Яка його поживна цінність? Коли корова востаннє була на пасовищі?
Чи зараз вона на пасовищі? І коли я, приміром, хочу підготувати її до отелення, то це лише дві кнопки.
І коли вона наступного разу буде в доїльному боксі, селекція відбудеться двома шляхами. І вона готова.
Наш шлях на пасовисько працює, зрештою, за тим же принципом, що і доїльний робот.
Корова розпізнається за нашийником, а потім прилад вирішує, чи можна їй іти на пасовище.
Все залежить від правил доїння, і для нас це просто чудово, тому що система відбирає корів замість нас.
Ми можемо випасати їх цілий день, але лише тих корів, які регулярно доїлися. Це економить нам багато зусиль з вигоном на пасовища.
Гаразд, ходімо зі мною. Я покажу вам своїх корів на пасовищі.
Для нас, компанії Bioland Hellmich, випас відіграє центральну роль.
Коровам потрібен простір, вони повинні і хочуть виходити надвір, тому вони отримують свою траву на пасовищі.
Технічний прогрес й екологічне сільське господарство жодним чином не суперечать одне одному.
Технології просто допомагають нам зробити нашу роботу ефективною, сприятливою для довкілля і насамперед ресурсозберігаючою.
Нині сільське господарство є дуже капіталомістким бізнесом.
Звісно, ми беремо на себе високі зобов’язання, щоб реалізувати проєкт із такими великими тваринами,
з відповідним комфортом для них, випасом та автоматичною системою. Це зрозуміло.
Це неможливо без певної впевненості у собі та без підприємницького ризику.
Це наш робот, який очищає шпарини. Він називається Discovery. Але ми ласкаво називаємо його Disco.
Він допомагає мені з щоденним очищенням щілин у підлозі.
Він робить це абсолютно автоматично 24 години 7 днів на тиждень.
Це величезне полегшення для мене, тому що раніше мені доводилося робити це щоранку вручну,
і результат був далеко не таким добрим, адже я робив це лише раз на день. А робот займається цим цілий день.
Загалом, робота на фермі має давати можливість отримувати задоволення від того, що ви робите.
Крім важкої роботи, яку ви робите щодня.
Мені вкрай важливі фази, коли ти можеш просто глибоко видихнути і насолоджуватися тим, що робиш.